[Musique]
bonsoir alors je sais pas vous mais je
trouve qu'on vit dans un monde en
perpétuelle évolution où les carrières
linéaires sont devenues obsolètes et où
la réconversion professionnelle est
devenu une réalité on prend conscience
finalement que le bonheur au travail ne
résite pas seulement dans un salaire
confortable
un statut social prestigieux mais
également dans la réalisation
d'aspirations plus profonde dans S
d'utilité et la réalisation à quelque
chose d'un peu plus grand que nous-même
finalement donc le bien-être au travail
est devenu un critère
important et pour appuyer ce point je
vais vous présenter une théorie celle de
l'aut l'autodétermination qui a été
introduit par deux psychologues Richard
Dessard pardon et Richard Ryan donc
cette théorie de l'autodétermination
elle parle des facteurs internes et
externes de la motivation
du développement humain donc de la
croissance personnelle et du bien-être
donc du bonheur
elle liste notamment trois besoins
psychologiques fondamentaux donc en un
on va avoir le besoin de compétences
avoir le sentiment en fait de maîtriser
ses tâches de pouvoir exprimer et
développer ses capacités ensuite en de
nous avons le besoin d'autonomie avoir
le sentiment qu'on est libre de ses
choix que nous pouvons contrôler que
nous sommes àinitiative de nos actions
et enfin en trois le besoin euh de lien
social donc avoir le sentiment qu'on
appartient à un groupe à une communauté
on se sent connecté accepté et
soutenu et donc en fait lorsqu'on
satisfait ces trois besoins c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on va se sentir beaucoup
plus motivé beaucoup plus engagé et
qu'on va ressentir un plus grand
bien-être à contrario lorsque ces
besoins sont entravés c'est là qu'on va
se sentir frustré anxieux et insatisfait
donc pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle
de ça c'est c'est parce que dans mon
ancien travail il est arrivé un moment
où je me suis senti beaucoup moins
motivé beaucoup moins engagé et où en
fait finalement entre autres certains de
ses besoins n'étaient plus satisfaits
donc je suis Nathalie j'ai 30 ans et
auparavant j'étais responsable opération
et service client pour une marque de
bijou en or et diamant et aujourd'hui je
suis barista nomade pour la ocofi
entreprise que j'ai créé il y a
maintenant près de 3 ans petite question
moi sondage personnel est-ce que vous
m'avez déjà croisé son bordeau au bord
de mon ah top levez la main ouais c'est
vous génial et qui a déjà goûté amé
spécialité j'esre que la prochaine fois
que vous me croiserez au travail vous
viendrez déguster à une petite dose de
laau COFI je compte sur
vous et donc pour revenir sur mon
histoire personnelle je suis la deuxème
d'une fraterie de quatre enfants la
seule fille je suis d'origine laoienne
et chinoise je suis née j'ai grandi en
haut de savoir entre Genève et
an alors plus jeune j'étais plutôt élève
studieuse élève modèle à rester dans les
rails les lignes bien tracé et j'ai
toujours été très attirée par
l'international c'est ce qui va guider
nombreux de nombreux choix dans ma vie
et c'est pour ça que j'ai fait des
études en commerce
international un cursus pendant lequel
j'ai également eu la chance d'avoir et
l'opportunité de faire une année
d'échange universitaire à cinet en
Australie c'est un élément important
pour la suite car c'est un élément qui a
été déclencheur dans mon envie de
changement de carrière et donc à l'issu
de ces études j'ai été recruté par cette
marque de Bau Suisse en
2015 en tant que stagiaire dans un
premier temps puis en CDI et il faut
dire qu'à l'époque je vagabondais déjà
beaucoup j'avais peur de j'avais du mal
à m'installer à m'engager sur la longue
durée en fait CDI me faisait peur alors
que finalement c'éit un peu le gral pour
pour les gens c'était la sécurité et moi
en fait je voyais ça comme quelque chose
qui allait m'enfermer et me bloquer pour
la suite mais bon c'était une
opportunité de rêve j'avais 23 ans à
l'époque quand j'ai pris cette ce poste
ça a été une expérience riche en projet
en apprentissage j'ai eu la chance de
diriger une petite équipe d'avoir des
responsabilités d'être autonome de faire
du télétravail alors que covid
n'existait pas encore et que ça n'avait
pas encore bousculer les les habitudes
de de travail euh j'avais aussi un
salaair très
confortable un équilibre vie pro et vie
perso super j'avais des collègues un
boss bienveillant donc en soit tout
était tout était top quoi
et j'avais envie d'international donc ça
c'est un souhait que j'ai mis très
rapidement au début de ma carrière c'est
ce qui a aussi ouvert une réflexion
auprès de mon patron qui à l'époque
habitait au Portugal et qui a donc à
proposé à toute l'équipe de venir
travailler avec lui dans les bureaux à
Lisbon donc opportunité que j'ai saisie
qui a été riche et exceptionnelle mais
qui m'ura satisfaite pendant 2
ans et donc
euh 2 ans au Portugal
euh j'ai eu un déclic euh j'avais tout
enfin j'étais heureuse globalement il y
avait quelque chose qui cl qui clochait
pourtant et ce déclic je l'ai eu en
rentrant de vacances c'était en été 2017
euh je me souviens encore de la scène
euh je je pensais que j'allais être
requinqué que j'allais être prête à
rattaquer le le boulot en fait je me
souviens encore être dans mon bureau
devant mon ordinateur à me demander ce
que je faisais là et là j'ai été frappée
par un profond manque de sens euh allé à
ça j'ai j'avais cette envie de voyager
avec mon sac à dos solo dans le monde et
j'avais maintenant les ressources mais
j'en avais pas le temps donc ce temps je
l'ai créé donc 6 mois après c'est là que
j'ai annoncé à mon patron que je voulais
partir de l'entreprise alors lui il
comprenait pas qu'est-ce qu'il se disait
mais pourquoi tout plqué pourquoi tout
remettre en question pour aller voyager
en sac à dos solo sans date de retour
après il faut avouer qu'à l'époque
j'avais pas du tout été honnête non plus
sur les raisons sur toutes les raisons
de de mon départ j'avais été incapable
de lui dire que je ne trouvais plus de
sens à ce que je faisais dans
l'entreprise vous me direz mais pourquoi
est-ce que tu n'as pas été plus
transparente parce que je ne sais pas
parce que j'avais peur de le froisser
que c'était pas mon rôle non plus de
remettre en question l'activité de
l'entreprise que je voulais pas renier
l'opportunité extra ordinaire qu'il
m'avait offerte à ce moment-là et euh et
donc 6 mois
après euh je prends mon sac à dos et je
pars
voyager en Europe et dans l'Asie du
Sud-Est et donc pendant ce voyage en
fait j'ai pris du recul et j'ai aussi
réalisé que au travail j'avais manqué
d'une vision du W donc de la résident
d'être de l'entreprise qu'est-ce que
nous proposions finalement autre que les
produits que nous offrions aux clients
j'avais manqué également de mentourat
d'accompagnement d'une personne un peu
plus experte que moi qui m'aurait permis
de me développer dans mes compétences
donc là on revient au besoins de
compétences de l'auto de la théorie de
l'autodétermination
ensuite en numéro 3 c'est aussi le
manque de d'interaction en face à face
euh notamment avec le manque de
collègues parce qu'on était une petite
équipe qui était dispaté partout en
Europe et en France et que c'était
seulement une boutile de e-commerce donc
très peu d'interaction finalement avec
des clients et donc là on revient aussi
au besoins de lien social de cette
fameuse théorie de
l'autodétermination et donc pendant ce
voyage euh c'est là que j'ai également
renoué avec un rêve qui a émergé pendant
cette fameuse année en échange
universitaire en Australie donc c'est
là-bas que j'ai découvert les cafés les
espaces les boissons que j'ai découvert
le métier de barista que je faisais en
job étudiant et donc ce rêve est resté
dans ma tête et dans mon cœur en disant
que plus tard j'urirai un c'est plus
tard c'est finalement retrouvé beaucoup
plus beau et c'est comme ça que j'ai
créé la hofi un café à ciel ouvert et
donc à mon retour de
voyage la décision la plus difficile ça
a été de la prendre finalement je suis
revenue j'ai tout de suite été assailli
de peur
d'angoisse de doute nouvelle carrière
changement radical de domaine création
d'entreprise le regard des autres le
regard de la société euh mais au final
une fois que j'avais prise que j'avais
pris ma décision j'avais mon objectif
clairement en tête et les étapes pour y
parvenir et donc en septembre 2020 je
crée mon entreprise donc je fais partie
de ces fameuses entreprises covid ça été
l'année record des création entreprise
de l'année 2020 et c'est début 2021 que
euh j'ai lancé officiellement mon
activité et donc euh si j'avais un seul
conseil à donner à des personnes qui
cherchent qui chercherait à changer de
carrière c'est ne rester pas seul
oser solliciter et interviewer les
professionnels du milieu les gens
adorent raconter leur histoire la Preve
je suis là pour vous raconter la mienne
et pour vous entreprise recruteur
établissement je me demande
finalement qu'est-ce que vous faites de
cette nouvelle réalité de cette envie
d'épanouissement de sens et de bien-être
au travail est-ce qu'il y a des choses
qui sont mis en place aujourd'hui si
vous rencontriez un cas comme le euh
qu'est-ce que vous aureez à proposer
est-ce qu'il y a des nouvelles pistes à
explorer je pense notamment en fait à
par exemple faire appel à des acteurs ou
des outils extérieurs à faire peut-être
de l'entrepreneuriat lorsque c'est
possible donc l'entrepreneuriat au sein
de l'entreprise à des passerelles entre
différents postes donc là on parle de
reconversion professionnelle au sein
même de l'entreprise également à des
temps partiel peut-être à des temps
adapté c'est vrai que dans mon cas je
suis partie de mon entreprise car par
envie d'exploration par manque de sens
par manque de mentorat par par manque de
communauté mais c'est ce qui a
aujourd'hui nourri ce changement de
carrière et j'espère que mon histoire
vous inspirera ou vous donnera matière à
réfléchir j'aimerais finir par cette
question est-ce que vous pensez que le
rêve et l'emploi sont conciliables merci
pour votre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention